- Not me, but I make sure
some of my homies, hold on.
I make sure some of my homies
I was gonna brace their death, right.
Middle of the day,
I make sure I book some of my homies,
have this on at nighttime.
(indistinct murmur)
- [Mark] Okay. What's your name again?
- My name is C Note.
- [Mark] C Note?
- Yeah
- [Mark] CENO.!
- No, C.I.N.O, Like a hundred dollar bill
- [Mark] Got it.
Okay. So tell me where you grew up.
- I grew up in South central Los Angeles.
- [Mark] Okay.
And what age were you
when you entered the gang?
- 14.
- [Mark] 14.
You grew up with one parent, both parents!
- Both parents
- [Mark] both parents.
- Yeah,
(Mark's indistinct murmur)
- I got cut as brothers and stuff.
We, we start, we started a gang.
We started it with mostly a
tagger gang, but the detective,
the hood we were there with the gang.
- [Mark] Right.
- So they wouldn't go in for it.
It was, we started a gang,
a for a hard time hustlers
and they was mostly tagging
riding on a bus stop and stuff
going to school and all that.
So at the time I was standing hoover hood.
So they said, you either gonna be a Hoover
or you ain't gonna be nothing and stuff.
So I turned to Hoover at
that time we was Hoover crib
and stuff.
So,
I turned to hoover,
really didn't know what
I was getting into.
seriously.
I really didn't know
what I was getting into.
If,
because
- [Mark] Because everyone's doing it
- Really,
following the fit in, fit in, but texting
and stuff like that, you
got your homeboy and stuff.
And even though I say it,
I say
I don't know what I get into
everybody around here call me Hoover.
You know what I'm saying?
No, seriously.
And it's hard when a person
don't really know what they getting into.
Cause a lot of people, peer pressing, see
you got people
everybody's take,
you got gang members then
you got gang bangers.
See, is a difference,
you got people that gang members
that ain't,
they from the hood
but they ain't put in no work.
You know what I'm saying?
And at the time I was growing up
you had to put in some work,
you know what I'm saying?
At the time I was growing up, like I say
I ain't gonna say no names.
You know?
It was mostly drive-by's,
you know what I'm saying?
And stuff.
So, I give you a hint
is a difference between a drive-by.
and when you really do somebody
cause I've sprayed to a lot of people.
It's, it's something me and
the Lord got to live with
me and the Lord, I say
you ain't never really did nobody
and stuff.
And then you wake up sweating.
You can't sleep and stuff like that.
And I, I tell a lot of my youngsters that
you know what I'm saying?
It's hard and stuff,
it's really hard and stuff.
I say, you got to get over that.
And I say, that's something you don't.
a lot of people kill they self,
cause they can't live with that.
They can't live with Siri.
You can't.
I say, when you shoot somebody like this
in the drive by,
you really don't know who you shot
but when you really
kill somebody and stuff.
It's, it's, it's, it's hard.
And you know, I explained that to
I explained that to them
and shit like that.
And,
it's something, it's this hard.
It's it's hard.
When I was growing up, it
was, it ain't like it is now.
It ain't like it is now.
See I was growing up.
You either, if you was a real gang banger
you was a real gang banger,
soon, you know
every gang-banger hit the County deal.
So when you hit the County deal
it was a real gang
banger, known gang banger
you was going to 4,800,
no, seriously, off the top.
you was going to 4,800 and stuff.
I did, you know, and stuff.
And I tell a lot people,
you couldn't make it.
People was getting rapped back then,
really raped.
You know what I'm saying?
It was people getting really raped,
stuff that I see
and stuff,
it's like
people would really get raped and stuff.
And like I say,
- [Mark] in prison
- In prison see people get
tortured on the streets.
No, I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
Torture, what I mean by torture is
scalp, scalp, no scalp.
And I asked my homie.
Really? What made you come up with that?
It would, it wasn't a problem.
Cause mom, pop work that night.
Mom was,
mom's let us keep guns in the house.
My mother let us keep guns in the house.
So it wasn't a problem with
guns and nothing like that.
I always made it a point
to come home after 2:30
in the afternoon because
my father be going to work then.
I tried to avoid him
and stuff.
- [Mark] What's wrong with
your dad? Is he violent?
- No. he was, I just, he was more strict.
He was more strict.
Then my mother was more lenient.
You know what I'm saying?
So I knew I could get away.
If I came
if I came with a mosque bird
in the house like this,
when he was gone and stuff
and
I mean one time, I went to jail
under my mattress
under my mattress, like
there, I had about four guns.
When I got, when I got
ready to get out of jail,
my father said, don't even come here.
Seriously, he told me,
don't even come here.
He explained to me like that.
And to be point,
where I got it from,
he knew where I got it from, okay?
I stole them from my next door
neighbor, who was a sherif.
He knew, okay
For hoover,
I've been sliced in the face,
sliced here, you know
sliced here, And at the time
- [Mark] You've lost friends.
- Cause I knew I had a friends,
just shot right next to me.
And blood on me.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- I had one of my closest friend
get shot right next to me.
I ain't gonna say his name (indistinct)
get shot closer to me like this
and blood on me.
And I ran
right
and the only reason I came back
is because
a female come from the West.
He was tight on me and that's it.
And I'm like, is he all
right? But I'm still panicking
and stuff.
I'm still panicking.
See a lot of people
put on that hard stuff,
Like they super.
And
I really know.
That's not you.
Okay. That's not, that's not you.
See when you a gang banger,
your whole thing, your whole slang.
Your whole mentality change
how you talk and everyday
you know, how you talk,
how you ride and everything.
Okay. A hoover!
Never ride a boat.
I don't give a fuck if it's in your name.
You ain't gonna write that oath.
No, ain't gonna write that oath.
You get what I'm saying?
If you write that oath,
spelling your name in school too.
You gonna cross the X out on it.
You ain't gonna write it in.
I mean serious.
When you're serious about it,
you ain't gonna write it in.
(indistinct murmur)
okay, a neighborhood
aint gonna right a three
or an eight,
without crossing it out.
(indistinct murmur)
When you say Hoover?
It put fear.
No, it put fear
because we blood killers, crib killers.
You know what I'm saying?
Anybody killer.
So it put fear in there.
Okay. I was worn out, through hell.
One of the reasons in a County jail,
L.A County jail.
Okay. They had,
They had to separate
us from the other gang.
We had our own floor.
The other gang had there own floor, know.
3000, 2000, 4000.
So you messed up and they said you was
from Hoover and went to that 2000 floor,
You know whats' gonna happen to you.
Cause they messed up, they came here.
No telling what's gonna happen to you.
You know what I'm saying.
I am, I'm be honest with you.
I didn't, step
In the county,
I'd have, I'd have stuck a
broomstick up an, an amigo butt.
You ain't around with your pack.
Aint a number who was on this cell,
aint a number who was on
his whole battalion floor.
(indistinct murmur)
c'mon man,
cause I went there
what's y'all gonna do to me.
I didn't get that.
You know, i didn't get that
I'd have made people,
I'd have made enemies drink my piss,
you know, strip them naked.
And i did that.
Like I said, I did stuff
that really
I don't want to think that,
God can only to talk to me and
ask me about.
- [Mark] So, so prison time, do you
- Oh, you don't even wanna know that,
prison time. let me give you a hint.
I went to prison 90.
I was a level one.
Okay.
Put it this way.
I went from a level one to a level four.
I skipped two and three.
No, seriously.
I went from minus zero
point to 177 points.
Okay.
I was on some of the roughest yards.
I've been Pelican Bay, Carissa City.
I've been
SUNY bill up there twice.
that's a high desert though.
Level four, 180, not 270,
180.
I've been to New folks.
That's Kern Valley and that's
where all the hardcore is at
people talking about
Pelican Bay is like this.
No Pelican Bay.
Ain't like that.
Cause you on lock down.
But all, all on point for Hoover.
For hoover.
okay,
you ain't on lockdown.
Okay.
When I get there,
first thing I say,
I need that burner.
I need a blower
straight up.
I need to pull it.
Okay. I've been told
how come I'm sailing with a non-affiliate
that I had a blower.
You know what the blower is right?
Blower is like,
a weapon,
a blower is like a knife.
(foreign language)
knife. you know.
Home made matchette.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not talking about a razor.
I'm not talking about a
razor on a toothbrush.
(indistinct murmur)
Yeah. I'm not talking about
a razor on a toothbrush.
Okay. I didn't have to.
I didn't have to get people
off the, from hoover,
I ain't have to get people off the yard.
And you wouldn't believe ,
what the other two that was with me
about to do said
I'm gonna give you a hint.
I had a homie call him Jay rock
could have been a professional
bodybuilders seal.
And he was really intimidated
and making the whole story short.
we had to get him off
the yard at high Devin.
So,
one of my homies Duck said,
man I'm trying to go to a level three.
My other homie said,
I'm not trying to go
home in a high desert,
Everybody knows something fit to go down.
You got the gang of police right here,
and everybody on the side,
they get you out of the room.
So we walked in the trap.
Let me give you a hint.
I thought it had happened on a Tuesday.
I go home Friday.
You have to get them off.
So when they say that I got mad, went off,
we get them off.
Okay. At that time I
did not have a blower.
Cause I probably have done this.
You know what I'm saying?
And nobody had both.
So we got them off.
They shot, they shot and stuff like this.
Let me tell you
my attitude and stuff would have got me
my neighbor, both of them, with a riffle.
And they said,
well said you stupid.
You're supposed to go home just like this.
You could have went home just like that.
And
he went like this.
He, in my attitude said,
Nigga,
I don't care how much time I got,
I'm still going home before you.
And before you knew, he
had something in my side
and said keep talking
you ain't going nowhere.
Now I'd be honest with you
I didn't got disciplined for
something I did, it appeared.
Okay. I get into it with somebody
I'm working in the kitchen
and he'd go like this happened.
And
I didn't tell my homie
about it, it hit the yard.
So when I was coming home
from work, mommy said, come
and I got disciplined.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I got into it with
a person and it was in me
that I didn't say nothing.
I let it go.
Cause I lost.
And my pride was hurt.
I lost so, I aint gonna go tell a homie.
It's standing here.
next day, guys waiting on me.
and really,
I thank God.
It wasn't discipline
they wanted to do to me.
it wasn't discipline.They wanted to
they wanted to, really
(fist sound)
But they say, I took the
discipline and stuff like that.
I took it and they said that's
because you only going home.
And I, and I, and I thank
God because if I wouldn't
they was gonna do me.
Its a, they was gonna do me.
- [Mark] what advice would you
give, to somebody out there
whose considering getting into the gang!
- Getting into the gang
I tell them that's not the
road you wanna follow down.
And I explain to 'them,
I explain to them,
what you're gonna get out of the gang.
You gonna get life in prison.
You gonna get killed.
Your family can get killed.
Your mama house getting shot at,
there's more better stuff than a gang.
Be, be yourself.
Don't be a follower.
Be yourself.
I think 99% of the person
in Gang is a follower.